consider the table with function values
for f of x is equal to three sine of
five x over sine two x at x values near
zero from the table what does the limit
as x approaches zero of three sine of
five x over sine of two x appear to be
so what they have is they're approaching
0 from below here so they're first
negative 0.1 and f of x is 7.239550
then we get even a little bit closer to
0. x is negative
0.01 once again we're approaching zero
from values less than zero and now we've
gone up to seven point four nine seven
three seven five we get even a little
bit closer zero and we get to seven
point four nine nine nine seven four now
let's see what happens as we approach 0
from above from values greater than 0.
when x is 0.1 it's
7.239550 actually the same as this value
right over here when it's 0.01 it's
7.497375 actually the same values here
and once again when we're at 0.001 so
we're approaching from above from values
greater than zero 7.499974
so this is an interesting thing the
limit in both cases seems to be
approaching getting closer and closer to
7.5 and so you could imagine that this
would be well let's actually graph that
just to verify it for ourselves so we
could type in our we could type in our
answer here and check our answer and we
got it right but just to visualize what
that looks like let's actually get our
graphing calculator so i have the graph
just to show you how i get here so if i
were to if i were to start on the if i
were to start on the home screen just
press graph
define my function of x and we could
just write
3 sine of 5x
3 sine of 5x divided by
divided by
sine
of 2
x
and then let me define my range
so let's see x i want it to be
yeah sure i can make it around zero and
let's see i'm getting y values that go
up to let's see around seven or eight so
i can make my y let me do a little bit
of negative y value so let me start at
negative one
for my y range and go all the way up to
let's say eight because this doesn't
look like it's getting above eight or at
least in the range that we're talking
about and now let's graph this thing
so let's see what it does okay so
the graph is doing all sorts of neat
things but then as we get closer and
closer to zero as x gets closer and
closer to zero from the negative
direction we see that the function is
approaching 7.5
likewise when x is getting closer and
closer to zero from the positive
direction the function seems to be
approaching 7.5 so you have this this
this well the function isn't defined at
7.5 but it seems like or it's pretty
clear that when you approach from both
sides you're getting there